[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un amoureux du
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
cyclisme michel callot été largement
réélu président de la fédération
française de cyclisme élections s'est
tenue ce samedi au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous étions
sur place
cyclisme encore ce dimanche de
paris-nice partira pour la douzième
année consécutive depuis les yvelines
cette année c'est la ville de saint cyr
l'école qui accueillera l'événement le
peloton passera le lendemain paroisse
ville sur mon siège plus d'informations
en ce magazine golf coupe projecteur sur
le golf de saint germain l'un des plus
beaux parcours d'europe qui a vu passer
les célébrités des légendes de la
discipline
focus non ce 7,8 sport l'actualité
sportive c'est maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
je vous le disais dans les titres pas de
surprise aux élections de la fédération
française de cyclisme annoncé comme le
grand favori michel callot le président
sortant était largement réélu à la tête
de la ffc ce samedi lors de l'assemblée
générale au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
il a battu son adversaire cyrille
guimard en engrangeant 93,42 % des
suffrages
il sera donc en poste pour quatre ans de
plus on écoute michel callot c'est notre
interview express c'est évidemment une
immense satisfaction parce que ça a été
ces huit derniers mois très difficile
très difficile parce qu'on a quand même
été confronté à une campagne
particulièrement violente
et puis parce que en même temps il a
fallu gérer comme tout le monde mais
cette crise sanitaire
donc aujourd'hui j'ai un profond
soulagement parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'on peut continuer un travail qui est
qui est important et qui doit être
accomplie et puis la portée et l'ampleur
du score donne une grande confiance et
surtout ça donne l'élan d'être porté par
par notre base
il va falloir comment qu'on regarde
comment on va sortir de cette crise et
quelles seront les conséquences pour
pour nous pour notre sport
et après ces quatre années exaltantes
surtout sur le territoire ici on va
aller vers les jeux olympiques de paris
2024 il y aura tokyo quand même cette
année donc sur le plan sportif très
dense pour nous on a vraiment à réussir
notre transformation économique et puis
presque culturelle de notre fédération
au regard de la montée en puissance du
vélo dans notre société donc les
chantiers sont vraiment passionnant et
je le qualifierais plutôt comme une
commune olympiade où il faut pas manquer
la fenêtre de tir mais où ça va être
très stimulant on a un objectif pour
tokyo qui était celui de 2020 qu'on
maintient en 2021 qui est officiel qui
est un objectif de 6 médailles c'est un
objectif que j'avais fixé au début de la
précédente olympiades qui ambitieux très
ambitieux mais on y va grandement sur la
liste de michel callot on retrouve
notamment un yvelinois un habitué de
cette émission jean michel richefort du
club de vélizy 78 qui sera dans le
collège loisirs du conseil fédéral
on continue à parler à cyclisme ce
dimanche le département des yvelines
accueillera pour la douzième année
consécutive le paris-nice cette année le
départ sera donné depuis à sancerre
l'école le lendemain c'est la petite
commune de wave il sur mon science qui
accueillera le peloton avec nous en
plateau alexandre joly vice président
délégué aux sports au département
adhésives in bonsoir bonsoir
alors est-ce que tout est prêt pour
accueillir l'épreuve ce dimanche non
seulement ces prêts en même temps c'est
un honneur et puis on commence à avoir
l'habitude néanmoins il faut
effectivement à chaque fois remettre
ouvrage sur le métier pour que ayez
aucun problème notamment cette année
avec l'aco vide sera donc dans des
conditions particulières oui justement
ça sera des conditions particulières
cette année est ce que vous êtes inquiet
ou est-ce que tout est prêt tout est
bien rodé je crois que ce type
d'opération il faut mieux avoir une
petite pointe pas d'appréhension mais en
terme de préparation oui tout est fait
et les équipes du département
les villes qui nous
accueil les services des communes qui
nous accueille
épaulé par le service du département ont
maintenant je le disais l'habitude et
s'éroder d'autant que les équipes d'aso
sont très faciles à travailler c'est à
dire qu'ils sont à la fois très
professionnel et puis en même temps et
toujours à l'écouté
donc pas d'inquiétude particulière m
vigiles rend jusqu'à la fin de la de
l'épreuve bien celui-là est ce que c'est
c'est un challenge peut-être
supplémentaires cette année de
l'organiser comparé aux autres années on
on l'a dit ça fait deux années
consécutives pendant dix années on va
dire ça s'est bien passé
l'année dernière c'est un peu plus
compliqué avec le co vie de 19 qui
arrivait en france cette année forcément
ça sera une nouvelle fois particulier le
site challenge de l'organiser c'est c
est un challenge louis
mais nous sommes dans ce département et
qui est terre d'excellence qui se veut
terre d'excellence pour le vélo c'est
j'allais dire c'est vraiment dans les
moments difficiles qu'on voit les vrais
amis et ce département est véritablement
un ami du vélo et du cyclisme c'est un
département avec plus de 400 mille
licenciés
je crois que je pense qu'une personne
sur deux fait du vélo dans ce
département
et puis en même temps les autres années
la foule pouvait venir plus de façon
plus importante
admirez les compétiteurs il restera
quand même une très belle couverture
télévision qui nous fera découvrir notre
patrimoine notre département et qui
mettra en valeur ce soir que l'on aime
tant
là on va revenir sur ce départ depuis
saint cyr l'école pour une étape de 166
km qui passera notamment par ben la côte
de senlis et versailles on partira d'une
commune historique du département dans
un paris nice c'est l'occasion de
montrer le patrimoine c'est ça ou vous
disais à l'instant exactement
c'est l'occasion de monter deux mois
près le patrimoine c'est l'occasion de
montrer que ce département à 80% à une
qualité de vie extraordinaire enfin la
qualité de vie sur l'ensemble du
département
mais à 80 % ce sont des zones rurales
des zones forestières et puis 850
kilomètres d'aménagements cycliste donc
et c'est un département qui est un
endroit stratégique c'est-à-dire tout ce
qui a été fait autour du vélo ces
dernières années puisque qu'on parle de
mon vélo dans les yvelines on parle
aussi de jeux olympiques on parle de 50
ha du vélodrome
et puis on parle du vélo avec je viens
de le dire
et puis cycle asselin pistes cyclables
et les ouvrages d'art qui sont mis en
place par le département pour madame et
monsieur tout le monde
alors le lendemain c'est la petite
commune de waimes ville sur mon sens qui
accueillera l'épreuve pour l'étape de
188 km en direction du loiret il ya
seulement 1000 habitants dans cette
commune de oignies de la subvention
c'est une volonté du département de
mettre en avant ses petites communes
c'est un petit peu une tradition un
chacal est une grosse commune une petite
commune s'est inventé le département
devient 100 m on a bien sûr peut dire
que je pourrai que ce département est
faite de zones urbaines 2 au nord est
réputé un patrimoine très riche que ce
soit bien sûr tout le monde pense à
versailles mais il ya tellement de qui
de petits bijoux dans ce département sur
lequel on et mettre en valeur donc
effectivement cette alternance est tout
à fait justifié et puis en même temps il
ya des raisons alors vous l'avez dit
sociologique ses dires il y en a pas que
pour les grandes villes le département
effet aussi donc on
on est dans ce département et on
s'approprie la courte sous ou alors les
habitants s'approprient la course et
puis en même temps il ya un petit détail
technique c'est qu'en général le départ
de la première étape se fait plus au sud
du département
ce qui tombe bien puisqu'on arrive dans
les zones rurales parce que ça nous
rapproche quand même de de nice alors
comment ça se passe pour accueillir une
épreuve du paris nice on s'approche on
se rapproche de vous du département
alors oui c'est ça c'est vrai que il ya
des demandes qui sont faites auprès du
président bédié et puis le problème
n'est pas de trouver des candidats jeu
je crois que c'est une fête savez le
vélo et la compétition quoi qu'on en
dise c'est un excellent vecteur de
communication
et puis en même temps c'est quelque
chose de très populaire dans le bon sens
du terme
je crois que font du vélo assad honte de
vos collègues journalistes y compris
renault mais qu'un chef d'entreprise que
quelqu'un qui sort du travail je crois
que le vélo et la course à pied sont les
deux sports accessibles pour tout le
monde donc on vient vous voir c'est bien
ça on écrit au président du conseil
départemental très claire à leur humeur
générale comme les élus sauront qu'ils
défendent leur lors quand on discute
avec le président les maires vont voir
leurs conseillers départementaux
mais effectivement la décision se prend
avec pierre bédier et la direction à
esso a quand même son mot à dire en
termes techniques pour savoir la
faisabilité
ce qui est plus compliqué quand c'est le
départ d'une étape du tour de france
alors ce partenariat yvelines à etsaut
paris-nice du coup va durer au minimum
jusqu'en 2025
vous ne serez pas le paris nice on est
d'accord on lâche malheur on l'a écouté
tant qu'on gagne en vous non mais c'est
vrai que c'est c'est fabuleux cinq ados
fabuleux et puis le
tour de france au mois jusqu'aux jeux
olympiques je crois qu'il ya une
certaine logique puisque les jeux
olympiques sauf en 2024
c'est autant de répétition pour toutes
les épreuves puisque on a peur on va
accueillir six ou sept épreuves dont
quatre autour du cyclisme qui va
s'étaler de poissy à 50 ha au vélodrome
jusqu'à la colline d'elancourt vous ne
voulez pas changer non on est d'accord
ça reste paris-nice sympa il vit nice
s'est pas encore prévu c'est pas c'est
pas prévu mais je crois que c'est dans
l'esprit des gens le département des
yvelines est maintenant je vire le
départ du paris nice n'a que ce que
j'avais le paris roubaix par bien de
compiègne c'est vrai alors est ce que
vous avez en favori pour cette première
étape saint cyr l'école alors j'ai
partir de maintenant question alors
c'est un peu piégeux parce que j'ai pas
regardé la liste avant de devenir où il
ya beaucoup de types qui ne viennent pas
directement et je sais pas si à l'autre
philippe est hélas et s'il est là oui
pour plein de raisons d'abord de voir un
maillot arc en ciel français depuis
bernard hinault je crois qu'on n'a pas
eu souvent l'occasion de le voir
en plus de ça c'est un très grand
champion de surcroît ce qui ne gâche
rien éminemment sympathique et très
disponible
l'eau sera moi à la con tenu des
conditions sanitaires mais c'est
vraiment un garçon qui est bien sur le
vélo qui est bien dans sa tête et qui
éminemment sympathique et sportifs comme
on les aime c'est vraiment une belle de
l'image de son sport français quoi qu'il
arrive en 2 vainqueur de la première
étape à saint cyr l'école si je
comprends bien
pas forcément pas forcément vous savez
que chaque jour il ya des étapes à peu
différente
ça va se jouer
vraisemblablement dans le beaujolais
donc il ya des noms comme chiroubles qui
vont parler à certains
nos amis épicurien on peut être sportif
et plus rien et assure nice et le départ
c'est-à-dire à saint cyr c'est c'est
quand même quelque chose importante
puisque de l'avs a découlé le maillot
jaune du départ ministre
c'est toujours important pour les
cyclistes donc ça veut dire un
engagement de belles courses et la
première étape une étape où
effectivement le vent d'ouest va frapper
et qui fatigue quand même beaucoup les
les coureurs cyclistes bon sur à ça avec
attention en tout cas merci à vous
d'être passé sur ce plateau pour parler
du paris nice je rappelle la course au
soleil passera ce dimanche et ce lundi
dans les yvelines
le départ sera donné depuis à saint cyr
à l'école merci à vous on va maintenant
parler rugby chez la décision est tombée
vendredi dernier la fédération of
française à l'issue de son bureau
fédéral a annoncé l'arrêt des saisons
amateurs 2020 2021 en raison de la
situation sanitaire en france est un
calendrier impossible à tenir
la ffr a notamment décidé de figer les
montées et les descentes pour tous les
niveaux sauf dérogation obtenue du
ministère en charge des sports
ce sera donc une saison blanche pour
tous les clubs yvelinois la reprise de
la pratique sportive à l'entraînement
pourrait quant à elle être envisagée
dans les prochaines semaines en football
il se souviendra de ce samedi 27 février
pendant longtemps libinois edouard michu
a joué ses premières minutes chez les
professionnels avec le paris saint
germain le joueur de 17 ans est entré en
jeu à la 88e minute lors de la victoire
du psg face à dijon 4 buts à 0
il a remplacé danilo pereira blessé ce
milieu de terrain heavy noah est passé
par les clubs du chéné et de versailles
avant d'intégrer le paris saint-germain
on devrait le revoir sous les couleurs
du club de la capitale il a signé un
contrat professionnel jusqu'en 2023
ce week-end est température était au
dessus des normales de saison avec de
beaux rayons de soleil l'occasion pour
certains de faire du sport en extérieur
au tennis-club de plaisir les courts
extérieurs les seuls autorisés à cause
du contexte sanitaire étaient tous
réservés un montage de romain respini
la météo les a motivé ce dimanche 28
février au matin ces sportifs amateurs
ont ressorti leurs raquettes pour faire
une heure de tennis entre amis au club
de plaisir ses licenciés ont réservé un
court extérieur sous un soleil quasi
printanier
quand je dors c'est un peu compliqué
quand il peut continuer donc oui je vais
effectivement le beau temps nous incite
à les joindre petit peu dur moralement
ça fait un bien énorme
ça fait un bien énorme oralement et
c'est vrai que ça nous redonne un peu
d'énergie un peu de de plaisir parce
qu'il n'a pas beaucoup effectivement
souvent dans la société
c'est excellent là ça fait un bien fou
on prend le soleil donc on est on est
très bien on peut pas rêver mieux là
c'est clair ce dimanche matin le tennis
club affiche complet que des joueurs sur
les cinq courts extérieurs ces terrains
sont les seuls autorisés à la pratique
sportive en ce moment avec la crise
sanitaire
ce taux de remplissage exceptionnel du
week-end est donc rendue possible grâce
aux conditions climatiques de ces
derniers jours
une première depuis de longues semaines
vous savez moi je suis un président
heureux quand je vois les cours qui sont
tous occupés ou quand je vois mes école
qui fonctionne à plein rendement
quand quand on fait des compétitions que
ce soit les interclubs jeunes ou adultes
et cetera c'est la vie d'un club
mais cette vie a complètement de
pratiquement disparu alors on essaie de
compenser en faisant quand même de temps
j'entends dès que le temps le permet des
animations à l'extérieur on en fait de
plus en plus au printemps le tennis-club
de plaisir pour accueillir encore plus
de joueurs en extérieur les différents
courts de terre battue seront bientôt de
nouveau praticable
après les gelées de l'hiver course à
pied à présent l'ultra trail 100%
elvinois la diag 60,18 ne se disputera
pas au mois de mars mais l'événement
n'est pas annulé mais déplacé au mois de
septembre 11 septembre plus précisément
pour nous parler de cet événement nous
avons nous avons avec nous en plateau
alain pelosse l'organisateur et bruno
bachelard trailer sur l'épreuve est
également organisateur bonsoir bonsoir
alors est-ce que ça a été dur de
reporter cet événement alain pelosse
alors oui ça a été fait a été dur fait 1
un grand débat e
entre entre nous pour savoir ça s'est
décidé le 1er février savoir si on
allait continuer à essayer d'espérer
voilà comme beaucoup de coureurs puisque
on n'était pas loin de 500 inscrits et à
un moment donné ça devenait un petit peu
compliqué pour nous mêmes de se réunir
pour mettre en place cette grosse
organisation
donc ça devenait un petit peu compliqué
ça devenait compliqué aussi pour revenir
des bénévoles pour les fédérer donc tout
ça mis bout à bout nous a fait prendre
la décision de repousser à à l'automne
enfin un début d'automne alors l'année
dernière on l'avait annulée à la même
époque
mais cette année on s'est dit il faut
quand même qu'on essaye de garder cet
espoir est de la faire sur 2021 bono
bachar vous confirmez vous n'aviez pas
le choix et un moment faut se rendre à
l'évidence les conditions sanitaires
sont telles qu'on veut pas se souvenir
on a du mal à organiser y arrive à les
voir des transports automatiquement by
far motiver les bénévoles avec toutes
les conditions respectant toutes les
conditions sanitaires
on avait on avait fait plein de plan b
on va dire un procès soit des
ravitaillements également en course pour
avoir cette mixité personnes or avec
tellement au bout d'un moment on dit
qu'on allait les vaccins nous a
encouragés à nous reporter cette année
et on espère que
le départ 11 septembre
si les conditions gouvernementales nous
y autorise combien de personnes sont
mobilisées sur cet événement on a à peu
près si on se réfère à la première
édition qu'elle ait lieu ont rejoint
donc c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois ça fait
une date différente le déplore mais la
première édition d'été 140 bénévoles au
total pour 400 inscrits donc forte
mobilisation sur certains événements
bien sûr
c'est vrai que là on était bien parti on
allait dépasser je pense les 700 ou 800
coureurs pour cette deuxième édition
avec la peu près le même nombre de
bénévoles et comme a dit bruno on allait
l'adapter aussi bien sur les
ravitaillements que sur le transport des
coureurs puisque je rappelle qu'on parle
d'un point a à un point b on parle de
breuil boisrobert pour arriver à
rochefort en yvelines
donc il fallait s'occuper de la
logistique transport pour les pour les
coureurs donc ça tout ça c'était
compliqué et sa demande
ça demande beaucoup de bénévoles et de
les réunir pour les briefer pour leur
expliquer un petit peu configuration
course m'a tout ça nous était impossible
dans les semaines qui viennent
donc voila c'était le choix qui a été le
plus raisonnable je pense donc un petit
peu plus positif à la course et est
reportée du coup mois de septembre est
ce que vous le présentez ce trail qui
devrait avoir lieu du coup convoi de
septembre qui va avoir lieu vous allez
voir il va avoir lieu donc je ne vais
pas cinq épreuves
une épreuve de 82 km qui veut partir de
breuil boisrobert un autre par deux
de saint léger en yvelines pour 1 42 km
et puis ensuite on va voir un 20 km au
départ de clairefontaine et puis tout le
monde va arriver à on souhaite aux forts
en yvelines avec une boucle également
rochefort rochefort une course de 12 km
avec également une épreuve de marche de
12 km voilà donc plusieurs distances
pourquoi alors pourquoi parce qu'on
s'est aperçu en fin de compte la diact
c1 les à bonal des yvelines c'est un an
maintenant on en veut on faire un nom en
tout cas et ont beaucoup de gens sur la
première édition alors on l'avait mis en
place sur le 46 km et le 20 km mais
beaucoup de gens souhaitent faire des
distances plus courtes 82 km c'est pas
rien quand même
même si le parcours est pas beaucoup
dénivelé mais ça reste exigeant
puisqu'il faut courir
la plupart du temps alors qu'on est en
montagne des fois on peut se reposer sur
une côte libyens ont posé entre
guillemets sur le fait de marcher là il
faut garder un rythme et puis on a fait
1 12 km pourquoi parce que on voulait
mettre en valeur la ville de rochefort
en yvelines
et le bois départementale rochon et
ligne qui est juste magnifique et très
peu connu et on voulait le mettre en
avant pour ça mais aussi pour remercier
la ville de rochefort en yvelines et son
maire je tiens à le dire car et je tiens
à dire à tous les toutes les villes qui
nous accueille
que ça soit brisebois robert
saint-léger-en-yvelines clairefontaine
en yvelines et roche warning vous voyez
que c'est quand même très yvelines la
diagonale des viviers matérialiser à
chaque fois on leur a demandé déjà sur
la première est la première normalement
ce qui devait avoir lieu le 27 mars ils
avaient donné leur accord
et là encore une fois on leur a demandé
de repousser
ils nous gardent notre leur confiance
envers nous et c'est vraiment on sent
soutenu et c'est ça qui nous tous aussi
à continuer et à espérer pour un départ
le concept on sait pour quel type de
public plutôt des bons trailer où tout
peut s'inscrire c'est la licence
distance qui fait la différence à
quelqu'un qui va s'entraîner trois
quatre mois qui court très régulièrement
sur du c'ur du sur la distance va
prendre de 80 kilomètres sans aucun
problème et a passé la journée à courir
et 40 km on commença on n'est pas dans
le temps commence à taper quelque chose
où il ya un entraînement assez soutenu
deux trois quatre fois par semaine avec
certaines spécificités et puis les
découvertes vont faire sur le sur 20 km
et puis sur le 12 km ou là effectivement
on va découvrir toutes les labels région
des roches on y vit une belle forêt de
roche mendivil et de clairefontaine
et puis on traverse les massifs
forestiers sont fabuleux donc celui
qu'on en a marre de courir il a qu'à
lever les yeux regardez où il est et
puis il prendra du plaisir aussi
alors la question comment fait pour
s'inscrire alors on peut s'inscrire on
peut s'inscrire dès à présent oui alors
on avait mis en place
on a informé donc les coureurs qu'on
avait reporté la date
certains ont souhaité annuler puisque la
date il internet s'affiche voilà mans à
l'écran voilà tout à fait et certains
coureurs ou ont demandé d'annuler leur
race autour parce que les dates leur
correspondait pas mais très peu
d'inscriptions et où on était 4 500 à
530 on est à 4 180 inscrits pour
l'instant donc les gens peuvent
s'inscrire il ya des gens qui ont annulé
mais il ya des gens qui commencent à
déjà se réinscrire
pour une course de rentrée de
rentrée qui va dire donc voilà en tout
cas je voulais je permets de ce moment
d'antenne pour remercier encore une fois
télé 78 parce que vous aussi vous nous
faites confiance et je vous remercie et
je remercie encore une voie sera présent
en tout cas j'ai un jour le 11 septembre
l'un du départ en tout cas vous remercie
et je remercie tous les partenaires qui
sont derrière nous parce que nous on est
des bénévoles c'est clair mais on sait
qu'on peut compter sur sur des
partenaires comme tels que vous et on
vous remercie
merci beaucoup merci à tous les deux
d'être passé sur ce bateau là direct 78
est donc programmé le 11 septembre
prochain dans les yvelines en espérant
par nouveau report the world
on va maintenant prendre la direction de
saint germain en laye la ville abrite un
golf d'exception le golf de saint
germain un club au passé un prestigieux
qui a vu de grandes compétitions
organisées à sur ses terres plusieurs
personnalités ont également tapé
quelques balles sur les greens en
montage de rémi lefebvre
il fêtera son 100e anniversaire dans un
an le golf le saint germain est implanté
dans la forêt depuis 1922 sur
d'anciennes terres agricoles le parcours
a été dessiné par l'un des meilleurs
architectes de l'époque harry colts le
britannique inconscient un parcours
forestier reconnu dans le monde entier
avec notamment 116 bon coeur à saint
germain est considérée suivant suivant
le entre employé le mot anglais au
ranking parmi les dix plus beaux
parcours de l'europe continentale pour
certains dans les cinq parcours d'europe
continentale mais c'est sûrement le
parcours le le plus célèbre le plus
ancien des événements le parcours
évinois organisé neuf open de france
dont le dernier en 1985 avec la victoire
de severiano ballesteros les greens ont
en plus accueilli la légende ben hogan
le célèbre golfeur au 64 victoires sur
le tour américain
les personnalités prestigieuses sont
également venus assange à mansle et à
partir de 1945 saint germain et l état
major de l'armée américaine et nous
avons reçu ici notamment le général
eisenhower le général m d'isère mais
surtout le général than à voir nous
avons aussi reçu ici le duc de windsor
qui venait régulièrement jouer au golf
de la propriété qu'il avait en bordure
du bois de boulogne
aujourd'hui le golf associatif reçoit
régulièrement des professionnels ils
organisent des tournois notamment des
championnats de france la structure
compte près de mille adeptes le plus
jeune à trois ans et le plus ancien 96
ans au delà de la compétition ce club
familial prône avant tout un style de
vie est membre d'un club comme saint
germain c'est accepter le cdc d'être
membre d'un club à la britannique c'est
à dire vivre comme ça pour son club
accepter les différentes compétitions
qui sont là et retrouver des amis et de
ne pas venir uniquement
taper des balles et repartir après une
partie pour rejoindre ce club historique
il faut être parrainé par deux membres
les admissions lieu deux fois par an
[Musique]
je
monstre
m
qui
vous
m
[Musique]
il est
on termine par une information golf la
légende de tiger woods a été victime
d'un accident de la route la semaine
dernière en californie
le tigre s'en sort avec de multiples
fractures à la jambe le golfeur de 45
ans devrait tout de même pouvoir
reprendre la compétition dans les
prochains mois l'américain est venu deux
fois dans les yvelines en 1994 lors des
championnats du monde amateurs et lors
de la ryder cup en 2018 les deux
compétitions et est organisé au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
on espère le revoir une troisième fois
dans le 78 il pourrait participer aux jo
de 2024 à paris s'il arrive à se
remettre de son accident
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]